give charity to
the rich yes or yes
do you want to prove do you want to
prove
that you have the christmas spirit give
to those that have
give to those that have
because it's real because it's real
there's no ulterior motive
give to those that have more than you
giving to those that have less than you
shows me that you want me to come up and
pat you on the back
for the things that you are doing for
those that have less than you
it's not right give to those that have
more
yeah if you see someone that's doing
well
help them do better that's
that's the real less the christmas carol
was great up until the end
when scrooge became a loser because what
scrooge was saying is
we have to work oh but mister i want to
go have
uh i want to go to the have the holidays
with my family
and screwed scrooge gave him a job
right scrooge gave bob cratchit a job
is it scrooge's fault that he had a
[ __ ]
no scrooge goes hey come into work
and be a clerk he even knows what that
is right with a quill pen
be a freak in that corner and i'll
[ __ ]
be a miser and run this ship
and then what did bob crouch you do i
forget
he goes i want to go home with my family
because it's christmas
and scrooge goes you better [ __ ] you
better figure it out
you better get this [ __ ] done and
and uh and i i don't remember i think
cratchit leaves cratchit leaves and goes
home to be with his loser
family his his son like
like his crippled son and his
disgusting wife and in this hovel that
he lives in
and then he's there and then scrooge a
[ __ ] king
gets harassed by these communist ghosts
aoc
bernie sanders and uh
i don't even know elan omar maybe
yeah ilhan omar i was going to say
cornell west because he kind of has a
ghost
look and then he wakes up the next day
and he goes buy the fattest turkey and
give it to
do this loser cratchit
it's not real do you understand that
they had to scare him
they had to send the ghost scrooge knew
he was right live
in the security that you are correct all
the time
even when you're not right be right
and scrooge by telling kratch you have
to work you can
things don't just happen you have to
work
is the best lesson of that does it
matter about the [ __ ] i want to eat
figgy pudding
yes yes yes but you must you must work
and that was the real lesson of the
christmas carol when he wakes up the
next day and he goes
here's the turkey and bring the turkey
to the family also like can you imagine
like that wouldn't even work like like
like he would send a turkey and like the
wife would be like this
[ __ ] guy who tortures you every day
sending the turkey over now like
what's his game what's this guy's game
this whole misers piece of [ __ ]
you know so that's how ben's wife feels
about me
like what i could i could do i could
deliver a uh rolls royce to the house
for both of them she'd go what is this
do you have the breaks in what do we
just try to kill me so that's my whole
problem with the christmas carol
is that it it's a it's a it's a it's an
assault on
on a business owner
scrooge and by the way am i
is the show sponsored by turning point
usa yes it is
and will i be doing a turning point
usa's re-reading of scrooge
yes i will and will i be doing it with
charlie kirkwood i just may
and me and charlie clark will re-read a
new version of scrooge where there is
respect
for the entrepreneur
okay and not some low-level
vagabond clerk and his [ __ ]
son we're doing a new version of the
christmas account with respect for the
entrepreneur
we're doing a new version of oliver
twist you know oliver twist what's the
famous line in oliver twist
can i have some more please sir may i
have some more
and the new line when me and charlie
rewritten it is sir i've had more than
enough and everyone else
has had too much and they're getting
lazy so can i please go back to work
that's the new line new readings of the
turning point usa's new readings of the
classics
with tim dillon and charlie kirk i have
not sold out i have bought in
[Laughter]
you see there's a difference between
selling out and buying in and i find
that
i just want a blanket i just hope
someone gives me a blanket